he said if we hit 400 and we have a
million dollar match
so we can formally be a 5 minute we get
half our goal today
hey what's up guys
good to see you markiplier here uh here
at my thankful stream thank you so much
for joining me on this wonderful live
stream doing a good deed
today didn't get the link in the
description kind of forgot how um
haven't done a live stream in a while
anyway we're raising money uh for
charity and um just thank you so much
for being here and uh
[Music]
hey guys thank you so much for being
here um why don't you check it out i
don't have a link in the description
because i i didn't do that
but
don't mind that guy anyway hey
guys you should totally
look for a link to a thank miss donation
page and go there
there's uh a lot of cool stuff
to uh do
there like donating to charity and uh
i'm
secretly live streaming from
sean's stream
i like hijacked it
he has no idea
he has like no idea
he doesn't know what i'm doing it's just
like none of the wiser anyway
there's a link
in his stream you could like go steal
that and like copy it and post it
and go to that
that would probably be the easiest way
to go about it i would put in the
description but i'm i don't know how to
do that i don't think that's a feature
that youtube has enabled yet
so why don't you go over to sean's
stream
it's youtube.com
jacksepticeye
and donate there
because
that
that's where the link is so go there i'm
good
okay cool yeah that's good man
try and get that donation girl
anyway come to jacksepticeye
[Music]